should we uh mr generate good of you to
join us this morning thanks very much
indeed i'm sure you're very well aware
of the imperial
uh college study uh suggesting that a
hundred thousand people a day
in england are being infected according
to their figures
how on earth did we get here
well we know that this is a very serious
situation now you can see across europe
governments having to take
very difficult decisions this is a
moment in which we need to all continue
to take
responsibility to follow the public
health guidelines the most simple things
being the most effective like washing
our hands
wearing a mask and staying socially
distant and we as a government
will continue to take action in the
places where the virus is most
concentrated
you've seen overnight that we've reached
a agreement with nottingham and
nottinghamshire
and then over the course of today i'll
be working with local leaders in
leeds and west yorkshire another area
where the virus is very concentrated
to see if we can reach an agreement
there we'll continue with our localized
proportionate approach of taking action
where the virus
is strongest but you can see from those
figures that the virus
is in a bad place in all parts of the
country so this really is on all of us
irrespective of where we're living today
that suggests that at least tier three
in london and the south then doesn't it
well we haven't taken those those
decisions we
are taking action as i say in the places
where the evidence very clearly
shows that the virus is strongest that
is predominantly today in the midlands
and the north but if it's required in
other places then obviously we'll
we'll follow the science and do the same
the the approach of trying to bear down
on it where it is most concentrated
i think continues to be the best way
forward because despite the fact that
the virus is rising across the country
it is very concentrated in some places
nonetheless and so that's the way
forward that we will continue to follow
yeah but that report is suggesting that
potentially we're heading towards an r
rate of
three in london and at the south east
we need to do something now don't we
well we are doing something now in many
of the places that you just described
like london
we took measures uh over a week ago when
london moved into
tier two that did mean further
restrictions uh which were difficult
at the time but now seem to be the right
decision and that
is helping to reduce the amount of
social contact
reducing the spread of the virus in
london
if we need to take further steps then we
will do but we're keeping that
under close review we don't want to
create a second national lockdown
we know that that has some effect on
bearing down on the virus but we also
know
that it's immensely destructive in other
regards to people's lives and
livelihoods
and to broader health and well-being so
we will do
everything that we can to avoid that
situation
by focusing on the places where action
definitely is required and you can see
that we're
we're doing that every day with the
discussions we're having with local
leaders
the longer the weight of moving into
tier three across the country or indeed
a circuit breaker
the more deaths there will be who will
be responsible for that
well there is harm in either approach if
you take a blanket
national approach that has some
advantages
uh you can see some european countries
moving in that
direction but you can also see how
immensely destructive that is in other
respects
you can see the harm to people's lives
and livelihoods
which will have long-term scarring
effects upon them
and their families you can see the
damage to mental health
the cases that get delayed beyond covid
elsewhere in the nhs and so the role of
the government
has to be to balance up those two
factors and take
a judgment about what is right in the
best interest of the country
a circuit break would not be a
short-term measure it looks like france
is
approaching as a four-week circuit break
at least
and so that is a very serious step and
one that we want to
try to avoid if we can it is right that
in the places where the virus is most
concentrated that we take further action
and i think those talks with local
leaders do need to be
speeded up so that we reach amicable and
constructive
solutions quickly in those places
sometimes it's taken
a number of days we now want to move
faster in those places so we can put in
place the measures that are needed
in places like nottingham and
nottinghamshire and as i say
we're moving into discussions with a
number of other parts of the country as
well
the chief medical officer and the chief
scientific advisor are pushing hard
we believe for a national circuit
breaker how regularly
do you review that
well the the prime minister and
ministers receive advice and have
discussions with
the chief medical officer his team on
almost daily basis
that's certainly guiding the work that
i'm doing in terms of
taking forward local restrictions
it was on the advice of the chief
medical officer and the joint
biosecurity center
that we took further action in
nottingham and nottinghamshire and it
will be if we take further action
in other places to come so of course
we're informed
uh by our scientific advisors we're very
grateful for them but as i say
they themselves would acknowledge that
the role of government is to balance
that out with the broader harms
that come with a full long national
lockdown and we will do everything we
can to avoid that
but obviously we'll keep all the options
under review as you would expect us to
so you're reviewing a national circuit
breaker on a daily basis
no i didn't say that i said that we take
advice from
our medical advisors on an almost daily
basis but the very clear policy of the
government is to do everything we can
to avoid a full national lockdown for
all the reasons i've just described
that it can cause a whole range of harms
both economic and in terms of health and
broader well-being to people across the
country and we don't think that's the
right
way forwards yeah and my question to you
sorry mr generic is
how often do you review a national
circuit breaker
well we are considering the options
regularly
but as i say at the moment it is our
very firm view
that that is not the right approach for
the country it is not a short-term
measure
it is likely to be for a number of weeks
if it succeeded
it is likely then needed to be repeated
regularly you can't have a stop-start
country
where businesses are closing people are
losing their jobs then they're having to
restart again
the harm to people's mental health and
broad well-being i think would be
immense
so we're not in favor of that approach
we have to do everything we can
to make a success with the proportional
but localized action
that we're taking and i'll say that is
now escalating
as we're taking further talks forwards
with other parts of the country
leeds west yorkshire is the next area
that i'm in detail conversations with
local leaders on
yeah but i mean the reason i i'm
pressing you on this mr general
is because they are doing that in wales
they are doing that
in ireland they are doing that in france
they are doing that
in germany um and they are taking all of
those
matters into consideration as well why
are they wrong
and the uh westminster government is
right
well these are difficult uh balance
judgments we don't deny that and we can
sometimes come to different conclusions
than
others our friends in europe or or the
devolved administrations
there are things that those governments
are doing which we have done for a
number of weeks and which have been a
points of
debate and discussion in the uk for
example uh having curfews and closing
pubs and restaurants early i've been on
this program before in which
uh you have understandably pressed me on
whether that made sense or not
other countries are now following us in
that regard
we are taking tougher action you will
see in some of
uh the localized approaches that we're
taking now in nottingham
and nottinghamshire the government
together with the local leaders have
chosen
for example now to limit the sale of
alcohol off sales uh so from shops and
out
off licenses after 9 pm so those people
who are
no longer able to be in regulated
environments
can't go and simply purchase alcohol in
the shops and then go and hang out in
unregulated environments so we're
learning at every step as to what
further steps we should be taking
but the government continues to take a
balanced approach here
which we think is the right way of
ensuring that we do bear down on the
virus
difficult okay though that's proving to
be while not
inflicting such devastating harm on our
economy
and our broader well-being okay i know
that you have to dash there another
couple of quick
points if i may police saying that they
will break up
family gatherings at christmas if they
break the rules is that the right
decision
well the police have a duty and a
responsibility to enforce
the rules we obviously want to ensure
that families can gather for christmas
i want to be with my own family at
christmas uh that's some way off
what we have to do now is take action
decisive action now against the virus to
give us the best possible chance
of being able to achieve that and that's
exactly okay what we're trying to do
okay so so yes they would be right to
break up family gatherings if they
if they didn't uh abide by whichever
tier the family was in
well i didn't exactly say that i said
that i'm not going to criticize the
police for saying that they
intend to abide by the law that would be
a pretty perverse thing for me to say on
your program
what i do want to have is families be
able to gather again at christmas i
think that's extremely important
i would love to do so with my own family
but the way to get there
is for us all to abide by the basic
rules
today and for the work of the government
and local leaders to progress swiftly
so that in those places where the virus
is concentrated we take decisive action
now and give the country the best
possible chance of being in a good
position
for christmas okay so the police have to
do what the police have to do more than
a million people have signed
the marcus rashford petition for uh free
school
meals for kids when they're not at
school
is there any point in me asking you
whether you might change that for
christmas
well we've said that we'll continue to
uh keep that
under review we all share the same
objective
of course we want to ensure that young
people and children get
the best possible life chances that's at
the absolute heart
of the moral mission of this government
of the conservative party
we're doing that in a number of
different ways recently
we gave 63 million pounds to local
councils so that they can help to
support children and vulnerable people
through the autumn that money is is
coming towards the end of
uh the period in which it was due to be
spent if we need to take further action
we will do there's no dispute on what is
our goal here
what is uh up for debate is the best way
to achieve it
and there there is a legitimate argument
about whether it's through
uh further advances in free school meals
whether it's through
targeted support of the kind that we've
been doing recently through local
councils
or it's through the benefit system where
also we've been putting extra money we
put nine billion pounds remember
additional funding into universal credit
and further support for local housing
allowance
to give families on the lowest incomes
in the country more money
in their pockets as they try to weather
a difficult year
okay as you know that 63 million pounds
wasn't necessarily for feeding kids and
the
mayor of liverpool said that they used
most of it on ppe but i must just ask
you before you go
well it was actually just to be clear
about that if you would
yeah absolutely well if you remember at
the start of the pandemic we launched
our everyone in program that helped to
get over 90 percent of rust sleepers
off the streets at the start of the
pandemic protected hundreds if not
thousands
of people's lives that work hasn't
stopped we've now got 29
000 people in safe accommodation who
were otherwise homeless
before covid we're now launching 150
million pound program
to buy over 3 000 units homes
for these people so that we can get them
into safe long-term
accommodation and get closer to our goal
which is to eliminate rough sleeping
over the course of this parliament
and to put that pernicious social ill to
bed
once and for all